what does elektra bring to the table
that captain america can't is victor von
doom really a better villain than ultron
we love the mcu we're not knocking it
one bit but the old marvel movies just
did some things better
there isn't a superhero film out there
at least on the marvel side of things
that tells a more compelling and
accurate origin story than the original
spider-man not only does it carry the
heart of the original marvel comic books
on its sleeve it combines the origin
directly with one of spidey's most
formidable foes likewise the 2005
fantastic four film angley's hulk and
the punisher among others set their
title characters up for success early on
how is this done by establishing a clear
origin story that often directly ties
our heroes to their most iconic villains
while mcu films like iron man and
captain america the first avenger stand
out as solid origin stories most mcu
films skip their inception completely
instead the films usually dive right
into the action to keep their audience's
attention that or characters are
introduced in another film before
getting their own standalone which also
often skip the origin stories this can
be a huge disservice to both the
characters and the audience peter parker
watching his uncle ben die bruce
banner's childhood flashbacks and
logan's frustrated attempts to uncover
his own story are what grounds and
guides the heroes plus who doesn't love
watching the fantastic four as they get
hit with cosmic rays from space he rise
and shine big boy how you feeling
there's no doubt that one of the things
we love the most about movies like
guardians of the galaxy and thor
ragnarok is the humor the blend of
character growth with self-deprecating
jokes is a true blue staple of the mcu
and for good reason it works i usually
spin it really fast and it would it
would pull me off oh my god emma put you
off the ground in fact many of us
rewatched these films over again just
for the laughs but the old marvel films
took a different approach while there
are clear moments of levity and x-men
spider-man and daredevil the films don't
allow the humor to hold them back from
telling more refined stories raymie's
spider-man trilogy is the perfect
example of blending spidey's humor with
compelling stories that feel honest raw
and genuinely human
i will
always be spider-man the x-men series
developed hugh jackman's wolverine in
ways that no mcu character has simply by
taking the character and his mythos
seriously rather than making a joke out
of them the only reason an incredible
film like logan could have even been
made is because of the groundwork they'd
laid with the character years prior
there's a lot to be said about a complex
interconnected universe where howard the
duck can chill with an immortal elder
and 20 years worth of peter parker's can
meet up to make meta jokes about their
various movies faults it's a whole lot
of fun for fans but it also means you
have to keep up with dozens of releases
to understand everything that's going on
one thing the old marvel movies really
had going for them was that they were
truly stand alone you didn't have to
watch ghostwriter to understand a scene
or two in x-men the last stand and
that's something of a lost art nowadays
we've all gotten so used to
interconnected stories and universes
that we expect them now at every turn
aside from the x-men and blade films
which really build off each previous
installment most of the old marvel
flicks can be consumed on their own
spider-man 2 is just as great if you
haven't seen the first film as it is if
you have and even elektra isn't
completely bound by the daredevil film
she first appeared in if captain america
civil war proved anything it's that
sometimes being too interconnected can
hurt the growth of your primary
characters and that's not something the
old marvel films had to worry about
rather each made sure to focus on their
own localized story before expanding the
world around them
since the foundation of the mcu the
franchise has struggled primarily with
their villains aside from loki thanos
killmonger vulture and one or two
baddies from the netflix shows many mcu
villains aren't terribly compelling
interesting or even believable most of
them don't stand out as anything other
than pale imitations of their heroes and
not in a good way the old marvel films
however understood their villains
completely our heroes main foes were
dark murky reflections of themselves and
not just because they had a similar
stark tech suit of armor rather they
made similar choices to our heroes but
with different results often warping
their own perspective of truth and
justice to fit their own agendas the
dichotomy between characters like
spider-man and green goblin professor x
and magneto and reed richards and victor
von doom is fascinating powerful and
full of surprises
in fact some of these villains are so
iconic that they even brought a bunch of
them back for spider-man no way home
atta boy
the old marvel movies also dealt with a
completely different set of
philosophical implications than most in
the mcu while iron man focuses heavily
on war on terror politics and the
captain america films reference patriot
act surveillance earlier marvel pictures
went for more universal down to earth
themes they dove into sociology
philosophy and even religion like the
original marvel comics before them the
x-men trilogy ran underlying themes of
equality hoping to remind us that people
should be treated the same whether they
have a difference in appearance or
ability this was ultimately the message
that stan lee hoped to convey with their
famed mutant characters and the fox
films handled it pretty well the
spider-man trilogy heavily promotes
moral notions of responsibility which
stand out among all superhero films as
being some of the most powerful ideas
explored in the genre the daredevil film
even touches on matt murdock's
catholicism and how his role as hell's
kitchen's guardian devil is heavily
influenced by his faith ghost rider
explores the moral and spiritual
implications of selling one's soul
likewise fantastic four much like the
mcu's guardians of the galaxy now
promotes the idea that you can find your
true family through friendships they
weren't always the best films but
there's no denying that the old marvel
films had a depth to them that has yet
to be fully replicated
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you